la chronique culture ce soit avec deux
invités qui nous ont rejoints aurélia
bonsoir oui bonsoir donc nous recevons
ce soir françoise pichon vous êtes donc
la conceptrice des comédies musicales en
hommage à edith piaf puisque cette année
c'est les 50 ans de sa mort et nous
recevons également side cyril pardon
vermander donc vous êtes concepteur d'un
site internet de d'écouté de musique en
streaming ou qu'on en revient tout à
l'heure donc on reste ce soir dans la
musique pour l'instant l'humour l'emploi
aux hommes humoriste s'est déroulé leur
hier qu'à la ferme du mousseau
d'elancourt 4 rue maurice était sur
scène nous en avons rencontré deux
d'entre eux dans le cadre d'un plateau
découverte est également le maître de
cérémonie qui était papier on les quotas
fraser de rire dénicheur de talent
acquis encore démontré ce mardi soir à
la ferme du mousseau à elancourt
l'étendue de son savoir faire son choix
s'est porté sur quatre jeunes humoristes
en devenir pour un spectacle découverte
d'univers très variés
on est dans la configuration du plateau
c'est con d'avoir la chance ce soir
d'avoir effectivement quatre univers
différents qui vont venir défendre les
uns après les autres leurs leur univers
pour le public c'est l'occasion de
d'avoir ce panel la d'humoristes
complètement différent après je vais
faire l'instruction des uns et des
autres mais c'est juste en maître de
cérémonie de ce spectacle c'est surtout
une rencontre avec le public c'est une
rencontre pour eux c'est un public
différent n'est pas paris on est dans un
public qui va venir qu'ils découvrent
peut-être pour la première fois ce que
cette le stand up qui a une
particularité quand même dans les mots
ristic et puis en plus il y avait l'idée
sur sur est en cours et sur
saint-quentin de montrer un peu ce
travail que de suivi artistique que nous
menons aussi avec des clips quoi qu'en
dise bonne amie julie galibert ou encore
ken khojandi connu pour sa mini série
bref se sont succédé sur scène ce sont
des soirées passées dans le rire et la
bonne humeur doublé suis chopé
est intéressant c'est est ce que les
gens voient être assez curieux pour
venir voir l'intégralité du spectacle là
ils vont avoir juste un aperçu avec un
seul personnage
pendant 20 minutes est-ce que ça va leur
donner envie à ses envies pour pouvoir
voir elle l'ensemble
je reprend là où j'en étais avant c'est
à dire je reprends pas là par la petite
porte l'humour et je crée mon humour
s'agit d'être marrant et soi même ça le
vrai combat puis j'ai rencontré à
l'époque
je leur ai juste à vendresse en fait
c'était il m'avait embauché dans la
troupe du jamel comedy club il avait la
gestion la trouve super moment et avec
lui j'ai compris dès vraiment des super
truc de pas forcément maîtres d'enjeux
dans sa prestation juste mettre du
plaisir et de la recherche aidé à créer
de la création sur avec le public et ça
c'est assez à s'écouler et puis c'est un
mec super détendu sur 10 mai invité me
when people je trouve avec avec plaisir
aux papilles ça se refuse pas
comme leurs aînés jamel debbouze ou
sophie aram peut aussi accompagner pour
acquis ce dont il conquérir le public
julie galibert sera le 20 avril au
perray-en-yvelines pour l'intégralité de
son spectacle c'est arrivé près de chez
elle quentin kyan khojandi en dehors des
planches il travaille aussi à
l'adaptation de brefs au cinéma
oui et donc par ailleurs papy que nous
avions reçues il y a quelques mois en
paieront le dieppois et plus d'une fois
ses passages en effet il ya quelques
semaines qu'il a été promu au grade de
chevalier des arts et des lettres par la
ministre de la culture aurélie
filippetti alors que celui-ci même donc
au mois de janvier qui présentait son
livre made in france s'insurger contre
ce système culturel institutionnel qu'il
jugeait on voulait dire qu'il dénonce un
système et il en profite en tout cas il
a critiqué mais alors du coup on lui a
posé la question mais pourquoi at il
accepté cette distinction en écoute
quand toutes ces institutions
culturelles repéré en fin de nos de
notre système français qui se dit être
l'exception culturelle du pays et que
c'est eux qui mènent la danse sur qu'est
ce que doit être la culture dans notre
pays je m'insurge effectivement contre
contre 7,7 position cette posture un peu
méprisante aussi de cette classe très
spécifique du monde culturel
effectivement que la ministre de la
culture fasse le choix de
de reconnaître mon travail en disant
vous avez fait un tel travail que je le
reconnais et à telle point je vous nomme
chevalier des arts et des lettres en a
pas tant que ça en plus donc c'est
vraiment là du coup je me dis il faut
que je saisisse l'occasion de montrer
qu'il ya un ministre qui dit qui me tend
la main en disant moi je vous reconnais
mon institution ne vous reconnais
peut-être pas mais moi je vous reconnais
je pense qu'il y avait quelque chose est
en train de changer sur sur le travail
que l'on fait sur cet accompagnement que
l'on fait voilà qui amène des jeunes
artistes comme comme sur ceux sur le
plateau qui va avoir lieu à la ferme du
mousseau qui peuvent se réaliser eux
dans l'ordre dans leur art dans leur
façon de nous parler de leur culture
avant et il ya une nouvelle culture à
faire je pense que l'insurrection
culturel est en marche merci madame la
ministre
papy chevalier des arts et des lettres
voilà ça c'est fait il a reçu cette
distinction il en est plutôt content il
pourra l'utiliser pour continuer son
insurrection culturel et demain nous
présenterons un reportage un peu plus
complet sur cette déclaration est en
l'occurrence son fils qui ne comprend
pas pourquoi il n'a pas de bain de dap
dp pardon c'est un chevalier cette
patiente romain tout un ensemble vont
pouvoir voilà elle est sur scène ça il
sait très bien le faire